hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast development of a
semi-automated
closed car team manufacturing process
presented by dr. Kelly Hirsch a
development engineer scientists to from
ccrm I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab routes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes labret is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box
that appear on that screen our speaker
will respond to your questions via email
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
the ask a question box and let us know
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and offers
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits tab
located on the far right-hand corner of
your presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining your credits
without further ado please join me in
welcoming our presenter today dr. Callie
Hirsch I will now turn the presentation
over to her welcome dr. Hirsch Thank You
Suzie and thank you to lab roots chabe
for the opportunity to speak about some
of the work that we've been doing at
ccrm to develop a semi-automated
close car team manufacturing process to
start out I just wanted to highlight a
little bit about ccrm which stands for
the Center for commercialization of
regenerative medicine this is a
non-profit company that was founded in
2011 with a focus to identify and
commercialize new discoveries and
technologies
located in acronyms Dever discovery
district in the heart of downtown
toronto we've now grown to over 80
employees continuing to specialize in
this regenerative medicine field and
then expanded to also take on cell and
gene therapy out
we have a large degree of expertise in
cell biology as well as process
development specific to us and sealing
up a number of therapeutic processes and
have recently entered into the GMP
manufacturing yeah must have regulatory
services IP diligence and strategy which
also associated with business
development strategy and our focus is
always innately focused on
personalization aspects and more
recently on company creation and and
incubating smaller companies so as a
whole caesium specializes in taking new
concepts and technologies all the way
through through to the market and onto
approval stage we can work on helping
build companies through incubations so
this is investigating regulatory IP
commercialization potential as well as
technology we have high technology
expertise to be able to identify these
these companies that we feel will have
success moving forward we have an
advanced provision shown in the dark
purple here this is actually a research
based group a wet lab group and they'll
take these early company ideas perform
proof of concept study and let us see
how easily and readily these
technologies may be translatable and
commercialized and more specifically in
this group we have a high degree of
expertise in cellular programming as
well as gene editing now moving on
through this process after
proof-of-concept discovery we have
another group called perturbation which
I'm part of on this is actually in
collaboration between GE healthcare and
the federal develop or sorry I said Dave
Ontario and here we take discoveries
that have been shown to work well in the
lab and we decide whether we determine
and figure out how to scale these so
that we can advance some of the
manufacturing processes that are up
there optimize them reduce costs and so
on and now we have a new division called
the deliverer division at C CRM and this
is our GMP facility which is opening at
October of 2018
where we're going to specialize in phase
one to clinical trial production we have
ten sweets here 14th outs
Beach and there are two sweets that are
dedicated to viral production and eight
sweets here dedicated to selling Chia
therapy manufacturing with over 25
experienced GMP staff members so going
back to the bridge division we again as
our comprise to both CCR m and G
employees and and the beauty of this
collaboration is that we actually
coexist on the same floor and work
seamlessly together a day in and day out
to achieve in advance different
processes so we offer persist
development solutions optimization
strategies we look at strategies that
will allow the greatest flexibility for
our clients as well as the industry
moving forward as well as a very
interesting scalable solutions across
the cell and gene therapy fields we're
also the process development arm for GE
cell therapy enterprises solutions is of
our notable treatments we have shown and
demonstrated scale of efforts for
pluripotent stem cells where we can
achieve up to 36 billion cells and
suspension culture at the ten liter
scale final production is another one of
our strengths so we have suspension
viral production systems serum free
we've shown scalability in these systems
and the ability to also execute on
downstream processing at this viral
material and we have emerging area of
assay development that's quickly
becoming one of our strengths what I'm
going to talk to you today about though
is our expertise and cellular
immunotherapies so the reason that we're
so interested in cellular amino
therapies is that these t cell therapies
are quickly taking off and showing
extremely great promise in the clinic
there's over 150 companies that are
pursuing t cell immune therapies and a
bunch of these are partnered with
academic and research institutes with
some academics going their own route to
put these products through the pipeline
and into the clinic so there's over 480
t-cell immunotherapy products currently
in development of these the most widely
studied
and and tested our car t-cells 75% TCR
products as well as chills so just very
briefly chills take our tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes take tumors out
of patients what they do is they grasp
the specifically the lymphocytes that
are associated with in this tumor
population they select for these
lymphocytes perform expansion of these
cells outside of the patient's body and
then infuse it back into the patient
what cytokine Qaeda il-2 in order to
treat the tumor and to regress its
progression and that's just shown on the
top here I by this patient base diagram
so car gene therapies and TCR therapies
are a little bit different T cells are
collectives our leukocytes reflected
from the patient T cells isolated and
then ultimately these T cells from the
patient are genetically modified when
synthetic receptors either car receptors
or TCR receptors and these genetically
modified t---cells are then expanded
further and infused back into the
patient and these T cells are unique in
that they can now target tumor cells
specifically to be destroyed and across
the T cell immunotherapy landscape and
the ones in clinical development the
bulk of these therapies are largely
associated with B cell tumors allow
non-hodgkins lymphoma
are the highest of those and the targets
are starting the synthetic receptors
himself chimeric antigen receptors this
is what the car stands for you're
comprised of a number domains so again
these are synthetic receptors which
contain an extracellular antigen binding
domain or a short chain variable
fragment that specifically targets the
cancer so this is shown as blue here in
your diagram and many of the car to
therapies that are out there now and
those have been approved on the market
are targeting cd19 and peaceful tumors
there's also a transmembrane domain that
anchors the car to the T so and this is
this this next domain shown just
downstream in the loop here as well as
different co-stimulatory molecules and
vation domains that help to facilitate T
cell signaling to enhance cytotoxic
effect of the car T cells and only to to
lead to tor death so as I mentioned
there are now party therapies that have
been approved for clinical use it was
exciting in 2017 see the approval of Tim
Raya which is used to treat personal
trials which showed eighty two and a
half percent remission rates in relapsed
refractory pediatric b-cell ALL patients
this was observed within three months of
treatment there's been approvals that
have been expanded for kim ryan now in
europe and in health canada and as well
the indication al l has been added as a
target for komaraiah both in the best
europe canada beyond this the second
karthik therapy that was approved this
name yes Carta it demonstrated again in
clinical therapies 51 percent clinical
remission in DL PLCO patients and is
also shown more recent approvals in
Europe moving forward so well party
therapies are demonstrating tremendous
promise in the clinic there's a lot of
excitement surrounding or surrounding
whether or not these could be the next
generation therapies for cancer is there
are still a lot of challenges that we
need to overcome specifically targeting
the tumors can be challenging
hematological malignancies we've now
shown some success but solid tumors
fighting antigens that are specific to
the tumor and not healthy cells has been
a challenge there's also side effects
that have been associated because her
she sells so cytokine response syndrome
has been shown in these patients
neurotoxicity t cell lysis b cell
aplasia so strategies to compat these
are continuing to be be studied there's
also a lack of control currently for the
approved therapies the ability to
control I should say car expression
so different groups are now
investigating how they can turn on and
off it's car expression in order to
prevent some of the side effects that
occur from car to treatment however I
think one of the major obstacles that
car key therapies need to overcome is
this high cost that's associated with
them and in the upper left hand corner
you'll see that a komaraiah's priced at
$475,000
373 with a slightly lower cost being or
slightly lower cost being attributed to
the fact that every patient treated will
need to pay this price and the higher
cost being that only those respond will
be paying
yes carta is similarly priced at 373
thousand US dollars however more
recently in Britain they've come back
and said that they will not be refunding
patients who receive these treatment
because the price is just simply too
high so some of the things that
contribute to these high costs are the
complexity in the supply chain logistics
once blood is taken out of the patient
it needs to be shipped in a cold
environment transported to a
manufacturing site where T cells can be
selected expanded modified so on and
then eventually transfer back into the
patient and this requires another
shipment step but the complex
manufacturing process also contributes
to these high costs and I'll get into
the details of just how complex this
process is moving forward but the
process in general is lengthy 17 to 22
days from the beginning to the end of
the process so that's we're taking these
T cells of the patient on putting them
back that's largely manual and it's open
so this means that it requires a lot of
hands-on attention from lab personnel
it happens in biosafety cabinets and
it's open to sources of contamination
this also increases the variability of
the car cheap products when you have
different hands on the product you don't
always get the same output and it has
been difficult to scale these processes
especially with a large number of unit
operations occurring in a BSc hood
so some strategies to deal with this
complex manufacturing process have
focused on developing instrumentation
for which you can take patient cells put
them in a box at the beginning and at
the end the transducer patient cells
will come out but someday Agent Smith
using these certain systems I have to
deal with the fact that you're locking
up this whole instrument for one patient
at one time so it's difficult to perform
concurrent cartoon manufacturing
processes so one of the more goals at
ccrm was to look at developing Kirti
process it was kind of a next-generation
Carty process we wanted to
systematically identify the unit
operations throughout the manufacturing
process identify how we could make it
more efficient we can automate it we can
close it and specifically we wanted to
identify and apply commercially
available reagents that would be
associated Henson's efficiency and
identifying automation strategies that
were currently on the market to reduce
these manual and open operations that
were can that were contributing to
process variability as well as
particular technician and the last thing
we were really focused on was the
ability to maintain the process in a
flexible manner so we wanted to look at
modular automated units that would allow
for multiple carci products to be
manufactured concurrently so to start
looking at the Carty process we began at
the beginning and on the far left here
is an outline of this manufacturing
process so very briefly you take a
frozen Linko pack that you get from a
patient it gets transferred to the Meg
data site at the site the Lego pacts
thawed these thawed cells are then
subject to a PBMC isolation which
generally involves a wash to remove the
lice grass blood cells is PBMCs and then
subject to a t-cell selection strategy
the T cells are activated they're put
through an expansion this may be a short
expansion period and then they're
transduced with the chimeric antigen
receptor after transduction the cells
are further expanded there have been
subject to our harvest at the
the process there washed to remove the
media and any other contaminant
contaminants they're formulated in a
cryopreservation buffer and then
cryopreserved
and shipped back to the patient so to
tackle this Karki process to begin
looking at automation we first started
by assessing whether or not we could
automate thoughts we go pack and the
PBMC isolation step see the experiments
we designed for this are shown just over
from the left we chose to compare a
manual method to an automated method in
the manual method we took frozen Lego
pack and traditionally as it's been done
we would thought we thought it in a
water bath following the thaw this Lego
pack thought Luca pack was transferred
to a biosafety cabinet the cells were
transferred into bottle centrifuge
washed multiple times and then subject
to a t-cell isolation in this T cell
isolation was manual as well for the
automated step for the automated method
we took this frozen lingo pack and
instead of using a water bath we did the
thaw in an instrument called the smart
max we then took this thought
Luco pack and we put it on an instrument
called C packs this house were
transferred into the instrument washed
to remove the light spread cells and
then the product from the C packs was
subject to a manual T cell isolation so
the results from this work indicate that
both PDMS of recovery and viability are
consistent coming out of the seat box
which is what was nice to see in
addition when we did this downstream T
cell selection so that would be to get
cd3 pot lit of cells which saw the cd3
positive cell recovery viability and
purity were all preserved using the
automated method versus the manual so
this indicated that us swapping away
from the manual procedure of the water
bath via C and centrifuge she's the
smart backs and C packs in its place was
viable strategy for our automated car T
process moving on now to the T cell
selection what we did was we wanted to
compare a number of T cell selection
regions we used a positive selection
method
we would isolate cd3 positive cells we
use two of these strategies with the
easy step method or another positive
method and we also used a depletion
strategy where we took cells that
weren't found to cd14 or 19 and assessed
how these cells would perform so for
these experiments we use these automated
strategies that we identified the
previous slide we took the frozen Luca
pack thawed them on the smart max
isolated Peas bmc's on the seatbacks 2
and then split the product from these
PBMCs into the different T cell
isolation methods following isolation
these cells were activated with immuno
called activators so these are CD 3 cd28
CP 2 T cell activators and all cultures
were expanded in a similar manner what
we identified was that using the easy
step isolation to get CD 3 positive
cells so if you had the highest
percentage of CD 3 positive cell
recovery or Tisa recovery and that the
purity remained high when we use CD 3
isolation versus that of a depletion
strategy and this is not surprising that
purity would be higher in this case we
also looked at how the cells expanded
after 5 days so this would be 5 days
post T cell isolation or selection and
demonstrated that there was really no
significant change in T cell viability 5
days post expansion and that the
expansion rates were similar regardless
of the T cell selection strategy so
given that the easy step isolation
method demonsaw see 3 recoveries and had
high purity as well as high by ability
and maintained nice fold expansion
throughout we slotted this easy step CD
3 isolations into our T cell isolation
method so now pairing this T cell
isolation method with transduction step
which follows downstream in this
workflow we wanted to see how we wanted
to see if the cd3 Easy Set isolation
method was also compatible with
efficiently transmission car T cells so
again we took PBMCs that had been
isolated on
see packs - we split them into different
key cell selection strategies so the
easy SEP see-through positive selection
a secondary CD through positive
selection and a CD 14 cd19 depletion
strategy activated them with amido
called expanded them and transduced
these cells on either day zero day one
or day two so this was also giving us
another layer of investigation to
determine whether or not these cells
would be more effectively transduced
earlier in the process or if they
benefitted from later on so just like in
the previous slide we identified that
cells isolated using the easy step
selection strategy had amongst the
highest level of transduction efficiency
and when we looked at how open basement
activation he cells needed to be how
many days post activation was suitable
for transduction and we identified one
day a post activation was most ideal so
now we've identified CD 3 easy step
selection method fits nicely into the
process we're using the immuno called
activators and identify that
transduction should occur on day one of
the process next we wanted to look into
how the Chi cells were going to expand
that we were isolating using these more
automated and closed strategies we
elected to use a media called Surya
media and we supplemented this with five
percent human syrup so for these
experiments what we did was we took five
different donors and we wanted to
investigate how will they grow or an 8
day period
split into this we also wanted to look
at how T cells would grow in a
bioreactor platform or the zuri w25 plot
so the outline of these experiments is
showing more or less in the middle here
this frozen Luca pack was subject to a
smart macro thaw PBMCs isolated on the
seatbacks again CD through positive
cells isolated using the easi sep and
activated with immuno called activators
then these cell for growing in zuri
media static flasks from day 0 to day 5
and on day 5 they were transferred to
Azuri bioreactor until day 8 of the
process
and as you can see across five donors we
get comparable both expansions that
occur around two hundred two hundred
fold expansion occurs for each of these
t-cell donors and we see that the
overall average their application being
sorry 173 plus or minus thirty across
the process cell viability remains above
eighty-eight percent and viability is
high on harvest day of day eight at
ninety seven percent so using the Zuria
media as well as coupling the bioreactor
into this process demonstrates that we
can achieve high degrees of expansion
with high viability at the end of our
curtsy process so well we liked how this
expansion profile looked one of the
things that continued to bother us was
that we were using static tea flasks for
our early expansion phase and we wanted
to see whether or not we could find a
strategy to replace this so what we did
is we came up with this early closed
culture alternative and we assessed now
how chief last expansion compared to
this closed culture alternative some
t-cells that have been isolated with
easy set seed iii+ met that inactivated
immuno called activators were Ida plated
on tea flasks for five days or in this
close cultural frenetic the relative
hold expansions were compared for these
different strategies and what we
identified was that they were more or
less similar regardless of whether T
cells were thrown at T flask or this
closed culture alternative so viability
was consistent across both of these
culture platforms and at the end of day
five we had a similar percentage of Sidi
through positive cells and the T so
subpopulations to see D for the CDH
didn't seem to suffer or change much
when T cells were growing in this closed
culture alternative compared to the T
flasks
so this is now allowed us to identify
early closed culture agile method and to
get rid of the T flasks in our Carty
process next thing that another sorry
another unit operation that had remained
open was our transduction step so to
look at how we could close this
transduction step and automate it we
assistant automated close transduction
method so for this we used the same unit
operations that we've previously used
all the way up to easy steps ev3
positive selection and activation using
immuno called activators the cells were
plated in Surya media aunty flasks for
one day after which they were subject to
different transduction about this so in
this case on the far left and gray
transduction performed on day one was
down at G flask so this was really a
static transduction that occurred
we also transduced cells in this closed
culture alternative to see how using
this would impact the transduction
efficiency of our t cells we used retro
method as shown in purple here and retro
neptune is commonly used to improve
transduction efficacy so we wanted to
see how that would compare to our
automated clothes transduction method
and then we used on the far right here
this automated method to assess
transduction efficiency and for each of
these methods they were either expanded
further of Lights in or remained in the
clothes culture alternative and in the
case of the automated transduction
approach following transduction we
transferred these cells to this clothes
culture alternative and for all of these
studies we used a multiplicity of
infection of 2.5 we've now tested two
donors would look bye buddy
for these cells either on day four day
five post activation we can see that
viability is more or less consistent for
all transduction methods but
interestingly this autumn it a closed
meditation that performs very nicely
comparable to the other transduction
strategies recessed or in donor five
even was with superior its ability to
transduce T cells so coupling these
observations now was what we've shown
above four different automation and
closure strategies are now able to the
transduction stage of the car Chi
process moving on further down the list
of unit operations in the car team
manufacturing workflow we know hits and
and to investigate this harvest and wash
step
as well as the formulation and
cryopreservation that we would need
steps that we would need to perform to
generate our Carty product to
instruments were identified for this the
sofia s2000 and the bio freeze so we
took cells that had been expanded in
Zuria media and on missouri bioreactor
for up to 10 days these cells were then
collected on the Sofia washed on the
sofia formulated in this case on the
smart max for the experiment and then
ultimately frozen in the bio freeze
looking at this workflow we see that
viability of T cells pre Sofia and Po
Sofia is high well above 95 percent
recovery sour coverage he's on recovery
post Sofia ranges around 90 percent or
ADH sorry 86 and viability once we now
thaw this car T product is as high as
well near near 100% so we also saw
relatively high post T cell recovery
indicating that we weren't losing a lot
of TC product by implementing these
automation steps
so both the Sofia s2000 and Biofreeze
were slotted into our car T process so
just as a summary for what I've shown so
far we've gone through all the unit
operations we've identified automated
closed solutions for the bulk of these
steps briefly we're using the smart max
to thaw the weakened pack C pax 2 to
isolate PBMCs
this easy step CD 3 positive step
unfortunately still remains open and
we're using this for t-cell selection we
transfer cells to a closed culture
alternative we activate with the you
know called activators expand cells and
Surya media transduction is performed in
an automated closed
transit or by an automated closed
transduction method cells are further
expanded in this closed culture device
for 2 days post transduction and then
they're transferred to a bioreactor for
further expansion where we have
perfusion strategies and different set
points that are maintained in order to
allow for efficient T cell expansion at
the
the culture we shoot gonna be shooting
for day a each but the for the results
I'll show you or at a 10 we harvest
ounces in the SF via s2000 on
subsequently cria formulate in the s2000
and then later freeze this hearty
product in the bio freeze so we're at
this stage now where we have performed
some simulated car t runs we've done
this using GFP virus and I'll just show
you where we're at with that so the
first part of the car T process the PBMC
isolation and t-cell selection as shown
here on this first slide for the leuco
pakistan and smart max PBMCs are
isolated in the c packs and then we have
an open CD through selection process
that is occurring using a magnet based
approach here the results from the two
donors are shown below we see relatively
high PBMC recovery following cells
coming out of the sea packs we also see
the viability is high it's maintained
above 95% and that td3 positive cell
recovery is in line to what we've seen
previously greater than 66 percent of a
CD through positive cells are recovered
on these cells are 95 percent pure and
remain highly viable now post CD 3
selection the cells are activated as the
amino called activators and they're
expanded further in a closed culture
alternative for one day after which
they're subject to transduction using
this automated transduction close
transduction method following
transduction again they are transferred
to the closed culture alternative again
and then ultimately search to the zuri
for this file I got expansion phase what
we see when we look at its theoretical
fold expansion across these two donors
that that we've looked at is that we can
achieve 120 10 or 10 billion transduce
t-cells on date which is pretty exciting
we transfer the cells to the zuri on day
4 which
point we see a really nice increase in
expansion rates and viability remains
high across the process we also have
noticed a nice level of transduction
efficiency using this automated close
transduction method where a day ten of
the process we have approximately eighty
percent which key cells that are may
transduced and when we go in to look at
the phenotype of cells that are
harvested and these results actually
shown from day eight but they tend a
similar we see that there's thirty
percent of the population that remains
cd8 positive nearly sixty percent sixty
six percent cd4 positive and then
looking at a cd4 and cd8 phenotypes
further a large percentage of these
cells reside in the central memory
phenotype with the CDA population
containing a number of naive cells as
well so when we look at the process
we're able to achieve 10 billion
transduce t-cells on day eight when we
start with 200,000 t-cells right pardon
me 200 million t-cells now moving on to
harvest stage so using a set the s2000
to harvest wash and crab formulate
followed by the preservation and the
Biofreeze we see the priests idea a sub
viability sigh this is maintain post Fe
as well recovery following the Sofia
also remains high and to donors which is
nice and one area that we are continuing
to work on is that recovery post saw
drops off once we take these cells out
of the liquid nitrogen tanks to see how
are they recovered next we also
demonstrates that cells remain a high
degree of GFP aggression with over 80%
of cells transduce once we recover cells
out of this cryopreserve state so what I
got three with you today is that we're
working on the development of a
semi-automated closed cartoon
manufacturing process we feel that this
process can be widely adopted across the
T cell immunotherapy industry we achieve
ten billion GFP transduce t-cells and an
eight-day process and we've now shown
that $2 we're using a number of
commercially available reagents that
includes the easy step release human CDs
three positive selection kits as well as
a meal call it's humans cd3 cd28 c2
t-cell activators and Zuri T cell
expansion media supplemented with human
serum beyond this we've identified
automated integration strategies to
remove some of these manual and open up
open operations salsa leads to a large
reduction in the labor requirements for
the process so aline she there are these
interests that yesterday with you three
out and while identifying these reagents
and automated strategies we've been able
to maintain flexibility of the process
so that we're not tying up any of the
instruments for prolonged periods of
time to prevent for their current
processes or products from being
concurrently manufactured so as for next
steps we're looking to complete more
simulated party manufacturing runs we're
moving on to perform a minimum of three
car to engineering runs or will also
assess the cytotoxic activity of our car
cheap products really interested in
identifying a close T cell selection
operation or even finding a way to close
this CD three easy sap isolation method
and now we're also investigating
strategies by which to improve our T
cell post recoveries and with that I
just want to wrap up by thanking a
number of individuals who have worked on
this project both ccrm and GE healthcare
employees as well as our funding from
that Dave Ontario in the Government of
Canada which supports our Center for
Advanced therapeutics all technologies
thank you and thank you dr. Hirsch for
that informative presentation and we
will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box and locate it
on a far left of your presentation
window and type your questions into the
box
that appear on the screen click the send
button our speakers will follow up with
you via email so let's take a look at
some of our viewers questions doctors
are the reagents described in your
presentation GMP compatible yes for the
most part all of the reagents that I've
discussed today are either Jim pika
miette now or they're in the process of
being or the device should be designed
to be GMP compliant and available within
the next year or so as well the
automated strategies that we use they're
all readily being utilized in different
manufacturing processes and can be
readily implemented immediately so
that's pretty exciting and dr. Hurst how
well the process change as manufacturers
aim to reduce manufacturing timelines
there's a there's a really big interest
in reducing the timelines for
manufacturing there's reports that have
shown that using cells that have spanned
it for less time you know have rare
efficacy at patients and I think the
ways we're gonna be able to achieve this
is by identifying specific T cell
phenotypes that creates the best effect
of patients so if we can identify these
phenotypes isolate them effectively and
then ultimately use this smaller
population of more potent cells to treat
the patients and I feel that it will not
only combat some of the side effects but
will also reduce these manufacturing
timelines and costs that are associated
with Carty process purvey thank you dr.
Hirsh and one final question how will
alternate or non-viral genetic
modification strategies influence the
Carty process so there's a great
interest in identifying different
non-viral strategies buyers production
is extremely expensive and it's a lot of
the cost contribution to what we're
seeing here for these car TV products
the issue with these non-viral delivery
strategies is that many of them are not
efficient
we have to get the efficiency levels up
there's also other methods such as using
transpose ons to create car t-cells that
are readily being used and showing
promise so I think this is going to
become you know a really fast-paced new
area of interest moving forward thank
you and thank you for your presentation
today do you have any closing remarks
you'd like to share with our viewers I
would just I just wanted to say I guess
that the process that we're developing
you know is very much still in the
development stage we're working to
completely completely automate this
process and close it and I hope that
everyone just enjoys the update that I
was able to provide today thank you and
thank you again for a presentation and
for your important research I'd also
like to thank elaborate for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to remind everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand through December 2018
please share that email from lab roots
letting you know that the webcast will
be available for replay and please share
that announcement with your colleagues
whom you've missed today's event that's
all for now and thanks for joining us we
hope to see you again soon bye bye